TONIGHT AND WE'RE UNDERWAY AND T
AND CHAISSON MAKING SURE THAT
THAT OF THE TO BURROUGHS WHO OFE
EKMAN-LARSSON.A PENALTY COMINGG
NOW DRIES.
TO GARLAND.
FEEDING IT BACK TO
EKMAN-LARSSON.
WITH ROOM. FIRST
MENTALITY, RIGHT THERE, THROWING
IT BACK, THIS TIME TO HUGHES.
HUGHES WITH IT.
DOWN TO MILLER, IN THE
KILLERS WHO HAVE TO CHASE AND
THAT LEAVES ELIAS PETTERSSON
OPEN FOROR: YES, SHOW HIM
AROUND.
[ Laughter ]
>> John G.: YEYE FOR
THE EYTON,
FEEDING IT NOW NEARCLOSING IN ON
ZONE, GARLAND THERE COMPLAINING
THAT HE WAS INTERFERED WITH BY
>> John G.: LAMMIKKO PUT THAT
PUCK ON HIS BACKHAND AND CORNER,
MILLER, IT IS HUGHES
BACK THIS TIME TO HUGHES AND
ELIAS PETTERSSON WITH A SHOT,
OFF OF THE POST AND THAT
MILLER, ACROSS, PODKOLZIN TO THO
FININI
WELL AND
COACH, YOU WILL WANT TO SLOW
THINGS DOWN HERE. LAST GOAL.
[ Laughter ]
>> John G.: YES, I HATE THAT.
6-1. CANNOT CATCH UP TO THE
>> John G.: WELL,T PUCK INTO
THE ARIZONA
TO THE ACTION WITH THE CANUCKS
TAKING